and gentlemen I Jonathan Trower being
the High Sheriff of heart future and the
returning officer at the election of a
member of parliament for the stevenage
constituency held on 7 may 2015 do
hereby give natives that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate at the
said election is as follows Collins
David UK Independence Party 6864 clocks
David independent 67 mcpartland Steven
Antony the Conservative Party candidate
20 1291 parmer Trevor Michael trade
unionist and socialist coalition 175
Taylor Sharon Jay labor and cooperative
party 16,000 336
van today Susan Elizabeth Kerr Liberal
Democrats 1582 Vickers Charles gem
Jeremy English Democrats putting England
first 115 white Graham Crawford Green
Party 1369 and I do hereby declare that
the said mcpartland steven anthony is
duly elected member of parliament for
the same constituency
the ballot papers rejected was as
follows waiting for more candidates
debate was entitled to 23 writing or
mark by which basically identified sex
being unmarked all hail avoid from
certainty 98 making a total rejected of
127 and therefore the total number of
votes cast was forty 7926 so may I say
well done to all of the candidates in
the campaign they've fought congratulate
the winner and invite any candidate who
wishes to do say to say a few words
starting with the winner
ladies and gentlemen it's a great
pleasure very humbling to be elected
once again as the member palm and for
stevenage and very provides have served
in that capacity over the last five
years and I very much look forward to
serve in that capacity over the next
five years a very grateful to those
thousands of people who put their trust
in me to work for them over the next
five years and I'm looking forward to
working with them to resolve some of the
issues that still face this time very
grateful to the staff proven and sure
there's been such a great count this
evening it's been gone very well they
pleased to as you can imagine I'm
grateful to all the people establish
with their votes I'm very grateful to my
wife and I man who's being a constant
support some adult whom I wouldn't be
able to do this job thank you very much
over my brain was my mother and father
who come to be with me this evening for
without them I wouldn't have been able
to fight for everything that I believe
is right throughout my life so thank you
very much for you've done
place give huge thanks to my campaign
team I can't name all of them but
Melissa Kathy Judy huge numbers of
you've done a huge range mean without
you we wouldn't have been in this
position to increase the vote the way in
which we did so thank you all very much
what you've done and finally I just like
to thank the people of Steve at once
again for putting their trust in me
thank you very much